et les loyers ont déjà l2
à quelques jours du 1er juillet c'est
celle est on toujours de se trouver un
appartement
l'édifice dans lequel elle habite a été
acheté par une entreprise qui souhaite
faire des rénovations majeures
elle a donc été évincé elle écume les
petites annonces depuis des mois mais
elle ne trouve rien d'abordable il dit
prix exorbitants ces propos s'ils
payaient cgt sens bien ce parcours de
passion j l épopée y est on sait quand
vous tapez l'électricité en plus pour la
télévision téléphone l'assurance-crédit
et respirer faut manger
monsieur une enquête du regroupement des
comités logement révèle effectivement
que les prix augmentent
un quatre et demi à louer sur kijiji
coûterait en moyenne 1300 17 $ à
montréal bien plus cher qu'ailleurs au
québec
la crise du logement elle est bien
réelle et les quasi permanente
le porte parole de ce groupe qui milite
pour les droits des locataires demandent
un meilleur contrôle des prix des loyers
il faut instaurer maintenant un registre
des loyers puisque les augmentations
important de loyer sont bien souvent
quand les locataires déménagent c'est
évidemment cher quand on regarde des
loyers spécifiquement mais de façon
globale les loyers au québec sont les
moins chers au pays
selon la société canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement 1 4 et demi
à toronto ou vancouver peut coûter entre
1500 et 2000 $ par mois le taux
d'inoccupation est faible partout 1,5
pour cent à montréal mais avec de
nouvelles constructions et moins de
nouveaux arrivants cette année la crise
pourrait s'apaiser
si cela se réalise en effet droguée un
peu plus au logement à louer dans grand
montréal par contre fos-sur-mer comparé
d'un point très bas
moi je veux destine alentours de verdeur
parce que mon médecin de famille et
l'eau - l'ophtalmologiste cgt ont des
racines peau et la basse
cécile a fait appel à l'office municipal
d'habitation de montréal pour trouver un
logement d'urgence ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morrell